National Geographic: Lithium, a soft, silver-gray
metal, is the third lightest element in the
universe.
Originally discovered in 1817 in a piece of
volcanic stone.
PBS NewsHour: We’re standing on some lithium
now, right?
It’s there, you just can’t really tell
it on the surface.
WION: Beneath the desert lies a treasure,
the white gold, better known as lithium.
SIERRA: Lithium.
Atomic number three on the periodic table.
It’s not one of the more famous elements,
like gold.
But behind the scenes, as countries compete
to get ahead in the global energy transition,
lithium has become one of the world’s most
valuable commodities.
Why?
Well it’s an essential ingredient in lithium-ion
batteries.
Not glamorous, sure.
But without those batteries there’s no way
to power an electric car, or store energy
from wind and solar.
As countries transition to a green future,
demand for lithium is exploding, and supply
just can’t keep up.
The world is going to need a lot more of it,
and without it, the fight against climate
change could come to a grinding halt.
I’m Gabrielle Sierra and this is Why It
Matters.
Today, lithium and the future of energy.
SIERRA: You know, I don't personally spend
a lot of time thinking about various metals.
So why should lithium matter to me or to any
of us?
VAITHEESWARAN: So I also don't think about
metals all the time, but I do think an awful
lot about my smartphone and I'll bet you lots
of our audience do as well.
SIERRA: This is Vijay Vaitheeswaran, the global
energy and climate innovation editor at The
Economist Magazine.
VAITHEESWARAN: They probably also think a
lot about the many other gadgets in their
lives.
And the main battery source to power all of
our gadgets and gizmos in modern life, whether
it's the smartphones, to the camcorders, to
you name it, these days use lithium-ion batteries.
Lithium is particularly attractive to engineers
because we're able to get an enormous amount
of energy storage.
You can pack 200 watt hours of electrical
potential into a single kilogram.
That's a five times improvement on the old
lead acid batteries.
So in a sense, you get a lot a bang for the
buck.
The costs have fallen by about 98% for the
energy stored in the last 30 years.
So it's a very, very attractive way to store
a lot of energy in a small space to power
an electronic device.
SIERRA: Batteries that use lithium are easy
to recharge and relatively cheap.
As a result, your home is probably full of
battery-operated objects that contain lithium.
But while smartphones and laptops and other
gizmos are great and all, the real reason
that lithium-powered batteries matter has
to do with something way bigger.
Clips: To address climate change, climate
change, change, climate change, climate change.
SIERRA: Climate change.
VAITHEESWARAN: It really comes back to this
question of energy storage, right?
It's not as glamorous as windmills or even
hydrogen, some people like to talk about.
Some people like to get into all manner of
new technologies for making electricity that
are green, but storing it is the other half
of the equation.
It's kind of the ugly duckling of the clean
energy revolution.
SIERRA: Lithium-powered batteries are fundamental
to storing and distributing clean energy.
There may be alternatives in the distant future,
but right now, there is just no way to make
clean energy work without it.
And this impacts another sector of the energy
transition - electric vehicles.
Ford Motor Company: It’s a driving experience
that’s pure, unfiltered exhilaration, from
the moment you hit the accelerator.
It’s the all-new F-150 Lightning.
SIERRA: According to the US Department of
Energy, highway vehicles release about 1.6
billion tons of greenhouse gasses into the
atmosphere every year.
At the global level, road transport accounts
for something like 15 percent of all C02 emissions.
And that means electric vehicles have the
potential to take a huge bite out of the climate
problem.
VAITHEESWARAN: Anybody who cares about climate
change will tell you, "Hey, we've got to get
off of oil."
And the most promising technology for getting
off of petroleum in transportation at least
for the next 10 to 15 years is electrification
and electric cars rely on lithium-ion batteries.
There aren't really a lot of viable substitutes
in the short term.
So yeah, we're going to demand a lot more
lithium if the electric revolution keeps taking
off, like it is, certainly in China, certainly
in Europe, to some degree in California and
parts of the US with the Teslas and so on.
And that's going to consume ever more lithium
to make those batteries.
SIERRA: An EV battery needs around 17-25 pounds
of refined lithium to run.
That's enough to power up to 10,000 smartphones.
SIERRA: So I live in New York and I have a
license, but I don't drive.
So I kind of feel like I don't have a grasp
on the role they're playing in car sales.
So currently in the US, how many car sales
are EVs?
FANNON: Yeah.
EVs are a tiny portion of the overall vehicle
fleet.
I mean, globally, it's not even double digits.
SIERRA: This is Frank Fannon.
Frank served as Assistant Secretary of State
for Energy Resources, and he is also Managing
Director at Fannon Global Advisors.
And he’s right.
Despite the flashy commercials, EVs accounted
for just 3% of total sales in the U.S last
year.
But that hasn’t stopped leaders from setting
ambitious goals.
Joe Biden/Guardian News: Now that’s why
today I’m signing an executive order setting
out a target of 50% of all passenger vehicles
sold by 2030 will be electric.
FANNON: There has to be an exponential growth
in demand.
And one of the things that the automakers
are doing, is they're putting real money behind
this, in this conversion.
I mean, some of these announcements that they're
going to exit the internal combustion engine
within the 10 to 15 years, depending on the
company, is an absolute tremendous scaled
sea change.
SIERRA: So it sounds like they aren't a big
part of car sales yet, but car makers and
governments are basically planning for them
to become the dominant model in the near future.
FANNON: Absolutely.
And this is a global phenomenon.
And there's an appropriate amount of attention
here at home in the United States.
But the biggest by far market for electric
vehicles isn't the United States, it's China.
SIERRA: Last year EV sales more than doubled
in China, with 2.9 million electric vehicles
sold.
That puts them way ahead of the United States.
But the US is seeing momentum.
MSNBC: Tonight Ford just announced that they
are hiring 11,000 new employees.
11,000 new jobs.
Bloomberg Markets and Finance: They’re gonna
ramp up their spending, but to the tune now
of $20 billion dollars to quicken their EV
production.
CBS Evening News: Ambitious declaration from
the CEO of General Motors tonight, the auto
giant making plans to spend $35 billion dollars
on EVs over the next 4 years.
SIERRA: All of these cars will need a lot
of lithium, and if we don’t have enough
supply, it could halt the momentum.
FANNON: Lithium is really bespoke to electric
vehicle technology and some other battery
storage types of solutions.
It's really instrumental to whether we can
achieve the targets.
And there's billions of dollars being invested
in this.
All of those investments are dependent on
a stable, secure supply of lithium.
Right now demand is far exceeding supply by
something like three to one.
I don't think we've reconciled this quite
yet.
But just the scale of this demand-supply gap,
according to a firm out of London called Benchmark
Minerals Intelligence, they've assessed that
in order to achieve the Glasgow Declaration
by 2040, would require 17 times more battery
quality lithium to be developed than is produced
last year in 2021.
SIERRA: Did you get that?
17 times more lithium than the world currently
produces.
FANNON: So how are we going to achieve this
is a huge, huge challenge.
And the other challenge we have is the time
it takes to develop one of these projects.
You can't just go to the store, like you can
go to the store and buy a new phone or go
to the Tesla showroom and buy a car.
It takes a long lead-time to develop some
of these mining projects.
And we are playing catch up.
SIERRA: So I guess this is when I ask you,
how do we get lithium?
VAITHEESWARAN: There's plenty of lithium.
That's the good news.
There's not enough lithium.
That's the bad news.
A handful of countries lead the production
of lithium in the world.
Bolivia probably has the biggest resources
in the ground and Chile and Argentina, its
neighbors, together they make up what's called
the Lithium Triangle.
They have lots and lots of resources in the
ground.
But Australia is actually the biggest producer
as a mining country.
They know how to do it, and they make their
lithium available to the world quite economically.
China has lithium that it produces, although
it's not one of the biggest producers.
And so does the United States, although we're
not one of the big producers either.
There are two main ways you get lithium.
Lithium is mined out of a rock.
That's the Australian approach, it's found
in deposits over there in that way.
In South America, they get lithium in a different
way.
It's actually kind of cool.
They have these salt flats.
These massive occurrences of lithium that
are underground.
So you drill through a layer of salt in order
to get the lithium out, and then you have
to evaporate it in these giant pools of water,
for many months at a time.
So it's slow, it's complicated, it's environmentally
messy, and it's not easily replicated in other
parts of the world or other places.
FANNON: So you have the mining of the material,
but that's just a raw rock, or kind of dust
in a bag that provides no useful purpose at
all.
Just like if you drill in West Texas and have
oil, it's not useful for anything.
You can't put that in your car and drive.
So too is the raw commodity of lithium.
What you need to do is go forward and refine
it, process it, and go through these stages,
till it meets a certain type of quality, that
then can be useful.
SIERRA: And while there is lithium all over
the world, this refinement process is largely
controlled by one country.
FANNON: China controls more than 60% of the
global processing capacity for lithium.
That degree of concentration represents a
material volatility, potentially in the price,
but also an oversized degree of control over
our collective clean energy future.
China's focus on this is a decade in the making
plus.
And they've been remarkably successful.
China's focus on these clean energy technologies
is really one of security.
They want to control the commanding heights
of the new economy.
And that is very much tied to the clean energy
economy.
VAITHEESWARAN: They have some lithium themselves,
but they're a huge importer from other countries
like Australia and from the South American
countries.
And the reason is they've built the supply
chain and the manufacturing processes.
They have developed a process for making lithium-ion
batteries at scale, a manufacturing process
that consumes lithium as an input.
And so they've got the electrochemical know-how.
They also have relatively cheap labor, relatively
lax environmental rules compared to Europe
or the US.
But to their credit, they also have lots of
engineering sophistication, especially in
electronics manufacturing at scale, which
is why they were able to develop, for example,
solar panels and transform the global solar
industry by bringing that to scale.
The electric vehicle business, which is related
to lithium-ion batteries, but not the same
of course, they have EVs at scale because
they're able to manufacture them and consume
them.
And in the same way, they've been able to
do the world a service to some degree by producing
lithium-ion batteries at massive scale, reducing
the costs so that everyone in the world can
benefit from this technology.
However, it does give them market power.
SIERRA: China’s dominance in the market
is a clear economic advantage.
But some observers think it goes further than
that.
SIERRA: What are the geopolitical risks then
that you see in terms of China's dominant
market position?
FANNON: President Biden, from the steps of
Glasgow, during the climate conference of
the parties, saw how oil prices were increasing.
And it was creating challenges at home.
No US driver wants to see high gas prices.
And so President Biden called on OPEC, to
increase production to lessen prices.
OPEC is a multi-country organization that
controls about 40% of global oil production.
However, China controls anywhere from 50 to
90% of the minerals and the processing capability
for the clean energy transition.
So just the concept of reliance on one sole
supplier creates volatility in price.
And that should be concerning for all of us.
Then if you put on top of that, that China
consistently is demonstrating itself to be
America's and the West’s writ large, greatest
strategic threat.
This opens up a whole new area when we are
transitioning our economy from energy that
we have an abundance of, in the case of oil
and gas, to one in which we are in a deficit.
And we would be extraordinarily reliant on
our greatest strategic threat.
That should give us all pause.
SIERRA: So are there incidents from the past
that might illuminate how China could wield
its market position?
FANNON: China in the case of rare earth elements,
rare-earth elements is a grouping of elements
and metals, and minerals that are used in
magnets and different things, everything from
wind turbines to electric vehicles.
So they're crucial, but they're not a big
market.
China became the world's leader in rare earth
production and processing, a lot of it because
it's environmentally pretty nasty stuff.
And China has a different standard set.
In 2010, China wielded its might in its dominance
of the rare earth supply chain, over Japan
specifically.
The two countries had been at odds over fishing
rights.
Japan took one of the Chinese fishing vessels,
took the captain in.
China didn't like it.
And so they withheld rare earth element shipments
to Japan.
The prices globally went up over 300% in a
few days.
So China has wielded its power and demonstrated
to the global market back in 2010.
More recently, just a few years ago, during
the height of the US-China trade war as it
was called.
President Xi Jinping visited a rare earths
plant in China through state media, and the
price jumped just then, and everyone was talking
about the possibility for a ban to the United
States.
That would completely stymie US and Western
security, as well as the clean energy transition.
SIERRA: China's dominance in lithium is growing
in many ways at once.
They own a lot of lithium deposits across
the world, and are buying up more.
They excel at processing.
And to top it off, China also controls nearly
75% of all lithium battery manufacturing.
As of 2020, it had 93 large scale lithium-ion
battery manufacturing plants, compared to
just 4 in the US.
VAITHEESWARAN: There's no doubt that having
an early leader advantage, first mover advantage,
in an important industry of the future is
helpful.
And you can see that again with the spillover
into their electric cars, which use lithium-ion
batteries for energy storage.
They're able to build up a supply chain tightly
integrated between those industries, the auto
and energy storage industries.
And you can imagine other areas where they
could gain benefit.
That's different from saying that it's some
kind of monopoly or cartel.
There's nothing stopping the United States
or Europe or other aspiring countries from
gaining competence and being really good at
manufacturing.
There's nothing stopping them from entering
into long term contracts, for example, to
develop resources of lithium from South America
or from Australia.
And so if you could give long term certainty
and advanced market commitments to purchase
lots of lithium from these countries, there'd
be much more likely to provide the investment
needed to develop their industry.
There's nothing the Chinese can do to stop
that.
SIERRA: So with this long term thinking in
mind, is this sort of why China has been so
successful at mining and refining lithium?
VAITHEESWARAN: There's a mix of factors.
Chinese five year plans are longer term by
definition.
You know, we don't really do five year planning
in the US government or most other Western
democracies.
That doesn't mean they're always right.
They make a lot of bets and a lot of them
don't work out.
But in a few strategic areas, at the moment
clean energy, biotechnology, and genomics,
they're pretty well advertised.
These are published reports.
We can all read what the Chinese say they're
going to invest in.
And they usually do invest in that area.
And it tends to give a little bit more certainty
to market actors.
But it also lines up the state banks that
provide subsidized aid or a nudge, nudge,
wink, wink, soft loan to a favorite local
company that wants to get into a certain area.
Why?
Because the party has said it's a national
priority.
Even if it doesn't work out, you'll be forgiven
for lending to a favored area.
SIERRA: Lithium and the EV market spotlight
differences between the economic and political
systems in China and the US.
China’s authoritarian system allows it to
set longer-term priorities and support companies
financially, even if they need to run losses
to meet their strategic goals.
VAITHEESWARAN: So you have this very, I would
say supportive network of both official as
well as unofficial ways of promoting some
of these technologies once the government
has sent its signal that they're going to
be supported for a while.
Whereas in the kind of Darwinian short-termist
capitalism that we tend to find in the US
and UK and some other markets, a company that
makes the bet wrong or is too early to a market,
if you come five years too early to an important
market, well that's as good as not coming
to the market at all or coming too late.
And your investors won't forgive you.
SIERRA: It’s unclear how China might wield
its market power.
But regardless of what it does, many observers
believe that it’s time for the US and other
countries to diversify the supply chain and
ramp up production in order to meet demand.
VAITHEESWARAN: No company would typically
get reliant on one supply source or over overly
reliant.
And in the same way, we should think more
broadly.
And if there are things we can do at home
to remove obstacles to investment within America,
to help scale capital, to get demonstration
projects out of the laboratories and out of
the national energy labs and Department of
Energy and into the marketplace, then we should
move much more aggressively on that.
And the soundings from the Biden administration
are this is what they want to do.
I think we're going to see this year several
things coming out of the administration, including
international summits I think that'll be organized
around this to focus attention on this, to
try to get a framework for reliable access,
maybe investment guarantees, maybe trying
to depoliticize this issue so that we don't
end up with a situation where one country
or another can bully others by guarding access
to resources, but rather have an international
trade framework, a multilateral framework
of access.
SIERRA: These frameworks might also take into
account labor conditions and human rights,
especially in the Global South where a great
deal of lithium resources are currently extracted.
FANNON: A lot of these countries, and particularly
in the developing world, are increasingly
concerned about doing business with China.
They're desperate for alternatives to find
non-Chinese investment.
Everyone knows about the Belt and Road Initiative,
where they make investments and it's kind
of rapacious.
They've pursued a similar kind of approach
when it comes to mining where it's just to
extract the minerals.
There's no investment in the country, no support
of the local community.
And it's really a shovel and ship mentality,
where they just come in, take, and then have
all the value accretion done in China.
So the country is actually left in a worse
place than ever before.
You know, when it comes to oil, there is a
concept of the oil curse or the resource curse,
where a country that is oil rich actually
ends up becoming worse off after the exploitation
of oil.
All of that has to do with the linkage to
corruption.
China is pursuing a policy that's very much
aligned with that, but focused on the minerals
for clean energy.
It's the same kind of playbook.
SIERRA: If the US became more active in the
lithium supply chain, it would have the opportunity
to invest in a more equitable way, especially
at home.
And that brings us to an option that we haven’t
talked about yet.
SIERRA: Do you think that we can mine and
refine our own lithium here in the US?
I mean, should we?
FANNON: Absolutely, we should.
And we have to.
To achieve our climate targets, we have to
find new sources.
And as I mentioned, the US has abundant lithium
opportunities, as well as Canada.
So yes, we have it, but what we've not done
is reconciled the license to operate.
It takes, according to the International Energy
Agency, up to 16 years on average, to go from
a mine discovery to production.
So if you think about that, the Paris Climate
Accord was only about six years ago.
We haven't really started discovering this
stuff and developing the mines, and then the
processing capabilities.
So that's absolutely critically important.
And we have to find new ways to do it.
We have to speed it up.
VAITHEESWARAN: There's no insurmountable barrier
in the US to America becoming a clean energy
powerhouse that utilizes lithium, makes lithium-ion
batteries and ultimately is able to take advantage
of the properties that lithium makes possible.
Now, what barriers we have, some of them have
to do with the nature of our capitalist markets.
A second area of course is nimbyism.
Lots of people don't like to have mines developed
in their areas, native lands, or even on federal
lands.
There's a lot of obstruction and there is
some water pollution that results from mining.
And so are we going to insist on higher environmental
standards or help the latest technologies
for environmental remediation be applied from
day one to give reassurance to communities
that this is not going to be just another
toxic mess we're going to leave in your backyard
and someone somewhere else will be driving
a fancy electric car thinking that they're
being very green.
So getting that right, and we're not there
yet.
I think that would help.
We're never going to be as cheap and cheerful
as China because frankly they run roughshod
over local communities, over capital markets,
over environmental concerns, over labor concerns.
I don't think we want to be that country when
it comes to making clean energy work.
But I think we can do it at a higher quality
level.
And we might see Europe as for example our
competitor or frenemy in this.
Europe is forging ahead pretty quickly in
this area and we might be able to learn some
lessons from the way that Europe is working
on this.
SIERRA: Well, it feels like such a funny cyclical
sort of argument.
Right, where, like, if I was being told that
there was going to be a lithium mine in my
backyard, I'd be, not too happy about it.
But then the argument is that, if we have
the lithium, we can use it for clean energy.
How do you reconcile that kind of conflict?
FANNON: You're right.
No one wants to have a mine in their backyard.
That's completely reasonable.
But every clean energy technology, however
clean and green it might be, requires a very
big shovel at the beginning of its life cycle.
Those shovels have to be deployed, or we're
not going to realize that clean energy future.
And, I would say most of all of us want to
address climate change in some way.
But operationalizing that is much harder than
just speaking about a big concept.
Environmentalists as well as certain governments
want clean energy.
But they're challenged on how to execute.
Again, the scale of what we're talking about,
500% increase in demand for these metals,
the trillions of dollars required in investment.
If you can't build something because someone
opposes it, however well intentioned some
local environmentalist might be, then you're
not going to make that investment.
I think that a certain segment of the electric
vehicle purchaser is buying that vehicle because
they want a product that doesn't pollute,
and that doesn't emit greenhouse gas emissions.
I think having that same consumer, be empowered
to understand where their supply chain comes
from.
And also to compare the way producing that
lithium in America would look, and processing
that would look, compared to how it's currently
being done.
I think this is the kind of awakening that
we all need.
And that starts really in your backyard.
We have to go from a NIMBY, Not In My BackYard,
to a YIMBY situation.
And this requires taking on very challenging
political constituencies at home.
SIERRA: Is that a yes in my backyard?
FANNON: Yes in my backyard.
Yes.
SIERRA: One of the first catalysts for climate
action was Al Gore’s documentary An Inconvenient
Truth.
At the time, the main challenge seemed to
be convincing people that climate change was
real and man-made.
SIERRA: The challenge has evolved.
Now that there’s growing recognition about
the nature of the problem, focus is shifting
to the question of how we actually alter the
infrastructure of our world.
As this happens, there will be a lot more
inconveniences along the way.
SIERRA: This new world of ours needs batteries,
and a lot more lithium.
If we are going to succeed, someone is going
to produce that lithium.
Sure, China is currently ahead, and there
are a lot of challenges, but the question
of who will lead this transition is still
up for grabs.
SIERRA: For resources used in this episode
and more information, visit CFR.org/whyitmatters
and take a look at the show notes.
SIERRA: Have a question or some feedback?
Just feel like saying hi?
Send us an email at whyitmatters@cfr.org.
SIERRA: Subscribe to the show on Apple Podcasts,
Spotify, Stitcher, or wherever you get your
audio.
And if you are a fan, we’d love it if you
could leave us a review.
Ideally a good one, the more stars the better.
It really does help us get noticed.
SIERRA: Why It Matters is a production of
the Council on Foreign Relations.
The show is created and produced by Asher
Ross, Jeremy Sherlick, and me, Gabrielle Sierra.
Our sound designer is Markus Zakaria.
Rafaela Siewert is our associate podcast producer.
Our intern is Roshni Rangwani.
SIERRA: Robert McMahon is our Managing Editor,
and Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital Officer.
Extra help for this episode was provided by
Kali Robinson.
SIERRA: Original music is composed by Ceiri
Torjussen.
Special thanks go to Richard Haass and Jeff
Reinke.
SIERRA: For Why It Matters, this is Gabrielle
Sierra signing off.
See you soon!